it's publicly now that you and Hillary
Clinton are friends already for decades
friendships in the political world are
rare what makes it that your friendship
has survived well I've known Hillary for
almost 30 years and I hope that when
this conference takes place
she's been elected president we share
common values political values but also
I think that these are deeply rooted in
our own personal experiences and these
values we've defended against all sorts
of people who have used whatever means
that they could many of them underhanded
in order to try and destroy reputations
attack people personally to engage in
what we've called the politics of
personal destruction but for a political
advantage and game it's not only that
that is a bond of friendship but rooted
I think in our common devotion to
advancing democracy in the country it
sounds like a cliche but but there it is
worry you're apart in age we grew up
five miles from each other we know very
much who we are so I think that there's
a rootedness as well in our commitments
and engagement does she realize the
enormity of the responsibility she will
get when she selected as
I think given a staple from wool I think
if anybody understands the
responsibilities of the presidency would
be Hillary Clinton having served in the
White House with her husband and having
been Secretary of State with another
President Barack Obama there are very
few people in American history who've
had that sort of background who risen to
the presidency and she would be a rare
person not only is the first woman but
simply as a person to assume that office
good fantasy with me and much looking
forward seeing you on November 12th and
after that